the video say those who've seen it shows
police in Memphis beating this man Tyree
Nichols pulled over in a traffic stop
January 7th it's described as Savage
senior investigators in Tennessee say
they've never seen anything so brutal
I'm grieved
frankly I'm shocked
I'm sickened by what I saw in now laying
criminal charges against the five now
ex-officers accused including
second-degree murder for each of them
local authorities made their position
clear while each of the five individuals
played a different role in the incident
in question the actions of all of them
resulted in the death of Tyree Nichols
and they are all responsible I'm not
watching the video though
you haven't seen it but I don't want to
watch it yeah I've watched it no why not
because I've I've heard everybody that
watched it everybody that watched it
said that it was horrendous like why am
I gonna [__] subject myself to that
and then add to the trauma that I
already have with police like I don't
want to see I've I've heard enough
people say that they saw it I had to
watch it I had to watch it because I had
to understand why they fired those cops
so fast remember we what we reacted to
the press conference before they
released the footage yeah and they said
these people are no longer and they're
gonna probably be charged yeah I said
they just got charged yeah
second second which is what I watched it
that's what that's what it was if you
haven't seen the video I'm gonna give
you a quick rundown uh but basically it
starts with body cam footage and the
body cam footage shows a cop jumping out
and yelling at the guy and they're hyper
aggressive off the top and then once
they're putting the dude on the ground
yes he's resisting a tad bit and you can
see it but they're also giving very
confusing commands you know what makes
me think of remember that hotel lobby
video you see of that white kid being
told all right put your hands behind
your back but don't move and don't read
and so he's trying to put his hands
behind his back but they think he's
reaching for his waistband so they're
giving confusing things a commands that
don't make any sense and they end up
shooting him and that to me honestly was
one of the most egregious things I ever
saw this was similar in that sense that
they're like put your hand down or put
it behind your back but one person's
holding his hand the other one's putting
the other hand so it's like very
confusing messaging and then they just
start pepper spraying him so the dude
panics and starts running
now irrespective of how you feel about
resisting arrest or whatever what
matters in this whole case is what the
officers did to him once they had a hold
of him rather than trying to actually
use their bodies and grab him and then
put him behind these dudes
there's no better way to describe this
it looked like a scene out of Mafia
you had dudes holding his arms and then
dudes was launching Haymakers and
kicking him in the face and I don't mean
like I'm talking about they were
unloading these are 250 pound men three
days later after you see it on camera
too because the body cam footage is not
very clear
but the footage from the post
the the lamp post or whatever it was
that [__] caught it everything and when
you watch that footage it's about five
punches two to three kicks and like he's
done he's out
and they're still launching on him three
days later he dies from brain damage and
the autopsy from the family they got
their own Corner basically said yeah
from bringing the swelling and basically
basically they're saying from the
punches in the kick I don't recommend
you watch the video but if you need to
see it go ahead so you can make your own
judgments but nobody can look at that
section and then say those cops didn't
go overboard they didn't just go
overboard they went well that's Murder
full stupid that's murder
is that not even stupid I don't want to
use the word murder
this is not like a mistake was made it's
not like lacking faculties these were
hyper aggressive cops that showed poor
amount of training in regards to how
they neutralize the subject and then
afterwards showed zero restraint and no
accountability towards the others when
they were going some that's clearly past
the line every cop I've seen who watched
this video said the same thing there's
nobody that has even tried to remotely
defend it so now you're looking at a lot
of people give her their different takes
I was gonna let you go what do you want
to say about this thing is I started the
video okay well this is what happened so
I had the link for the video okay and
then I started it
and and I paused it and I was like
no
not my feeling that one I'm no no it's
like
I'm not I'm not like I'm feeling cop
videos
but it's really just it's really just
I've like you don't remember like a
couple of times back then when we were
covering police stuff oh yeah and I was
like super tired oh yeah you covered the
first eight to ten police videos and
then by the 12th or you're like yeah
and I gotta I'm gonna I gotta subject to
that and I I I I sometimes
um Facebook
it shows me videos like that and I start
I'm like I become tense yeah in the
shoulders my jaw yeah everything is like
I got not [__] and now like everybody
that saw it that I know that I saw it
from bottom thing they're like oh that's
brutal it's brutal and it's also why I
tell people don't do street fights it
only takes a few punches for you to kill
somebody
it only takes a few you could listen
honestly there was like eight hits in
there but I guarantee you he was
probably done it out by the first three
to four
this is why it's not a joke because
people get brain swelling and then they
bleed and they die
I mean you watch that [__] and it really
looks like a criminal organization
putting out some Street Justice and no
one can tell me otherwise and the thing
with cops
is that it's never been a question of
color
for me
it had nothing to do with color
to me
if you're black and you're wearing a cop
uniform you're now blue
before you're black white same thing you
don't it don't expect it doesn't matter
yep it doesn't matter it's the
organization itself that I'm like oh
that I got an issue with whenever they
stop it makes me think of whenever we
were kids and then the teacher would uh
designate someone out of the class to
watch over the class and once that
person had the power that person would
turn into a whole ass [__] and then
you're like yo yo what do you what are
you what do you what do you do what are
you doing like what is this what's this
you're acting brand new the only thing
is that these cops are acting brand new
with guns in people's lives that that's
the thing that's a bit messed up and I'm
telling you a lot of these cops are not
do not have the the the the proper
training to de-escalate situation that
is not what they do that is not what
they do they entice
and they get you to prove to get
provoked and then they charge you with
whatever you got provoked on so you got
to be very careful that's why I don't
really like the wisdom some of them are
really yeah yeah you're saying oh yeah
we'll preacher talk about all cops you
talk about our cops whenever you're
gonna be held accountable it's gonna be
after the fact that it's too late not on
the moment when it happens
that's not what happens you you do that
after the fact
when you watch our conversation
afterwards and how they're like pretty
nonchalant about everything it indicates
to me that they've done this many times
before
imagine all the people they beat like
this I didn't go and die
think about that the body cam footage
honestly just looking at it you wouldn't
have been able to tell exactly
everything that's going on it's the
footage from the lamp post think about
the times they did this when there
wasn't a Lamppost
think about how often this [__] happens
when nobody's around and there's no
cameras to film think about all the
police departments that are fighting
tooth and nail to refuse body cam
footage think about that it ain't just
about this case it's about the issue at
Large
how easy these [__] did that
[__] you know it's not their first time
it's crazy because you look at people
that work in a call center this is
called maybe recorded for quality
purposes Come on B you know damn well at
the late and in some call centers they
pull out two random calls from but you
cops don't want to be subjected to body
cam it's a lot of resistance a lot of
resistance for the body count why cause
you know you [__] up I understand to
some degree because there's some such a
heightened degree of scrutiny when it
comes to everything cop does so even
reasonable things that cops do people
scrutinize for example let's say A Part
pulls out a knife and he starts swinging
at people folks will say well why did
you shoot the leg if you look at the
body cam footage it's like ref some of
you guys and the things that you demand
cops to do or is not reasonable for
anyone with a trade weapon there is no
training in the world that tells you to
shoot people in the leg but people say
that the public is so hyper scrutinizing
cops every single thing they do that
they are being ridiculous with their
dimensions and so cops be like they
can't even do their job and even when
they do they're not appreciated for it
so a lot of cops are actually just
leaving the force in mass in some areas
um and so I understand the frustration
there on the other side listen these
guys had multiple complaints against
them already in the past think about
what they've done to other people
wearing that badge it just comes with
extra responsibilities and there's some
measure of oversight that needs to be
implemented but a lot of cops are more
concerned with protecting their own than
serving the public think about it even
the guys who weren't doing the punching
but were holding the dude they didn't
stop a metal
they didn't stop though the dude was
punching them their job is to protect
the public but instead they prioritize
the other guys who are wearing the same
uniform the people that they were
elected to protect and serve are the
ones that they're harming why maybe some
of them had second thoughts and they
didn't feel tough but they wanted to
protect their own when you see stuff
like that it makes you look at cops a
bit differently that's not what they're
hired for they're not hired to protect
the public
yes you're right they're not hired to
protect the public they are hired to
protect the people that hire them that
pay them you know I mean they're they're
here to protect the interest of the city
and the interest of everybody that's in
there in the government they're not here
to protect
it's like talk it's like thinking that
HR is here to protect the people working
there no any places that call humans
resources is not here for the humans
but to take them as resources so let me
ask you go ahead they did fire everybody
and charge them with murder right away
isn't this what you want to see that's
what I want to see but here's what my
problem is is the accountability what I
have a problem is the accountability
whenever when that happens it's too late
we lost the [__] you understand
and I understand that that's what they
have to do and everything and stuff but
yes that what they did they fired it
right away there was no [__] what
the department did
I Gotta Give it to Caesar what they did
is what they were supposed to do I do
have to give it to the briefing the
department be like whoa
we I can't hide this I mean you there's
no way they can't I they think I can't
hide this I can't you know it was this
it was this burnt exactly this or we're
losing the whole city
is that we're losing I can't no and she
was and the fact that they released the
footage on top of that just just the the
transparency I feel I feel you know what
I'm a good question that you ask I feel
like there's some things that are
changing it's a bit too long for me but
you know change requires times and I got
that I understand that right in the
department you got to give it to them
they did what they were supposed to do
okay
some people feel as though the main
reason why the department acted so
quickly was because the police officers
were black
to that I will reply
the problem is not that they acted
quickly is that they should act like
that with white officers that's it
that's it the wonderful thing though is
that I feel that's my little side of
Hope
I feel like other precincts that are not
going to act according to that like like
that is it like a is this like a
precedent you know I mean it's just like
something like where people are looking
at this like no no these that's what
they did you better everybody's gonna
remember what happened with those
officers so the ones after that because
of course there's going to be other ones
people are going to look at them are
going to look at their Precinct in front
and be like no no that's that's what
that's how we act from now on
that's how we have from now on so if
you're telling me they acted quick
because they acted quick because they
were black I will say they didn't maybe
they did what they were supposed to do
me maybe because what they were black
maybe but now even if it's a white one
they need to do the same the problem is
not that they acted fast because they're
black promise that whenever they're
white it's a bit weird
so I think they didn't act fast they act
accordingly the other things well they
need to step it up for the other things
but this this was supposed to happen
like that
I think outside of the Derek Sherman
thing I don't remember seeing too many
instances with cops that were this
flagrant not too many
my feeling
is that because this was caught on
camera so clearly and this they were
doing stuff that had nothing to do they
beat him like it was Mafia that's what
they did it wasn't a self-defense thing
where you could argue or whatever they
held the man and they basically murdered
him
sorry they murdered him
I think because the footage was so
severe they had to fire these people and
I'm quite confident this is my belief
You can disagree we can all disagree
that this is five cops holding a black
man like this
grabbing him by the arms my apologies
you do you're good right and doing both
and grabbing them right
and then swinging Haymakers I'm very
confident
they will Define us maybe you disagree
but I don't remember seeing footage like
that do you
other than Derek chauvinway you know
what you know what yeah and even if we
don't remember and there has been
it doesn't change the fact
it doesn't it doesn't seem anything what
I'm trying to say is exactly what was
caught on camera this might be the most
egregious thing I've seen
problem
this this is the one for me surprisingly
of all the footages I've seen that was
the most crazy because you have it on
camera so maybe you guys have a
different recollection again let us know
um but me I think that's what really
determined the severity of the
punishment because personally I've seen
plenty of precincts defend black police
officers who were in the wrong in
certain situations and generally they
prioritize the uniform above racing to
anything else to me it was just
it's hard to look at that footage and
think police you literally think gang
so I think that's what really determined
the fast action not the race but that's
me personally it's not it's not it's not
the issue
but but it is because if you're alleging
that this only happened because they're
black and that then well that's not the
case I think the footage is actually the
reason that's what I'm trying to get
footages the footage is is literally
I've never seen I saw I saw the position
of the camera and and and I saw the
clarity of what it is and I said no I'm
gonna see everything and that's why I
have to stop yeah yeah this is this is
very unique
because even with the George Floyd stuff
people are saying well his system gave
out where was his knee on his neck and
I'm like uh you can try to make that
defense but I don't think it's Gonna Fly
that looked like murder to me this one
you can't make a defense I'm gonna tell
you this those cops are going to snitch
so fast on each other to get police the
ones who held the arms and didn't do the
swinging are going to be snitching on
the men who did The Swinging I promise
you yay yeah
you best believe yes from cop to CI you
best believe yeah it's not just
criminals who do snitching cops do too
yes
they gonna do some Talent oh I promise
even if they let them because they're
going to be like no no no no no no no we
we will let them don't let them they
want the ones who was doing the swinging
and the kicking they're gonna be gone
yeah they're gonna be going someone's
snitching so I just want to say that
anything else you want to say no all
right let us know what you guys think in
the comments below did we miss anything
in regards to the family and I mean this
is terrible and you know the family
watched the video first and I couldn't
imagine watching one of my loved ones
being murdered like that in front of me
on camera
uh and so you know the the family I feel
for them that actually gave me shivers
when I went back to watch a press
conference because
I remember watching the press conference
before where they described what they
watched and then watching the footage
and I'm like you know I would have been
crying for days so you know that uh that
really hurt me so
don't recommend y'all watch it but hey
yeah yeah that's my that's my thoughts
anything else